in New Hampshire they're having a bit of
a Democratic primary tonight knew where
that yeah wow that really was a terrible
spot in the indicative of what's
happening in this country he really do
like booed did the whole election oh
yeah yeah that's the same response I get
if I asked that question in New
Hampshire
just like a moose kind of clapping
Cerrone again you've just seen a moose
shrug big Democratic primary in New
Hampshire today and president Trump went
up there did you know that he went to
New Hampshire to kind of mix things up
mm-hmm yeah yeah he's just a
troublemaker that guy Eddie he had a he
had a rally at a rally in New Hampshire
president Trump urged independent
supporters to vote for the weakest
Democrat yeah in response they said
you're going to have to be more specific
okay hopeless there's like nine of god
because because he voted to impeach
President Trump Republicans are now
referring to Mitt Romney as Judas now of
course if Romney is Judas that makes
President Trump a Jesus that was married
three times and comp with a pornstar
that's a Jesus that gets around oh that
that's over yeah
today today Joe Biden said that Mickey
Mouse could run against President Trump
and have a shot that's what he said yeah
Ben Biden Biden found out that he was
pulling third behind Mickey Mouse
[Applause]